okay we're talking about the pie game
right yeah okay
so you know how last time i was talking
about the
we were talking about the food game the
tr food transfer games
foods into each other's mouth and i was
like this is a sexual thing they know
that
people are into this wet and messy
fetish yeah okay so there's also a
fetish
for pieing women in the face and so i
have a video that i want to show you
i said this to luke
this is uh this is a from a site called
pie hole or the pie zone this is a
i was working on a video about this i
never ended up doing it this was the
same video as the wet and messy fetish
but i'm like this is too too weird i
think like i don't want to like
but anyway so this is a website that you
pay for where all it is is videos of
women getting by in the face
okay what's the what is it pizon.com
i don't know why that's just curious
okay
has anyone seen my pies
oh hello mr bear have you seen my pie
has do you think you've seen them i i
think
who stole the he doesn't seem like
someone would steal pies
i make a whole batch of big creamy pies
big big creamy pies
[Music]
bad bear oh that's nara brown bear why
would you steal her big creamy pies so
perfect
so big and gooey don't you get any idea
about
me in the face don't you dare bro bad
bear don't you dare bear
oh he did it oh my gosh
i can't believe
i love i love a girl it looks like a
broken graham cracker and a marshmallow
oh dude
like an incomplete s'more yeah dude
what the [ __ ] michelin man just
busted a nut
no like the michelin man popped his face
so dude the michelin man [ __ ] turns
me off
well that's crazy so i was working on a
video yeah and there's a whole fitness
yeah by working on a video i mean i was
working myself off
yeah yeah yeah yeah research
working on getting myself off let this
finish i gotta see
pie hole pizza
look at me my pretty dress is rude
all right i'm creeped out get this away
from me
oh that's like just the beginning too it
gets weirder
so anyways you know i think the
producers may
you know either know a little piezo.com
yeah yeah they're just
just softly trying to promote yeah or
they know about all these weird little
fetishes
and they're they're integrating them
into the show to hit
every single sexual fantasy
to maximize the audience that's my
[ __ ] conspiracy theory
sorry i don't want to cross streams here
but now i'm just picturing dana white
promoting piezo
it's [ __ ] friday and i'm here at pie
zone
all right to answer one question who
stole the pies
don't you [ __ ] do it bad bear
don't you [ __ ] do it
you know what it's actually better than
you would think
oh [ __ ] but yeah pie dash zone.com
i hate i hate when sharon left everyone
acted like
they had to like bury like you know a
soldier or something yeah it's like
dude nobody reality show nobody really
cares
people's people are going to leave when
brad
[ __ ] left jake was a mess
yeah crying a mess he kissed that dude
on the next
time i couldn't yeah bro he's my best
friend in the villa
he's just giving him a little hickey on
the neck
dude i'm gonna miss you bro yeah he was
he was torn up about that it's really
torn up
sharon laughs it's like and brett was
holding him on his neck like don't stop
keep sucking keep sucking my neck
um yeah sharon bounced up out of there
you know then hugo had the weirdest
reaction to that
like he like almost like punished aj
from for choosing
it did he he was like yeah
i knew when you've picked me like you
know it's just it's just difficult
because sharon's like my best friend in
here yeah it's like dude come on man
come on have a little bit of romantic
charm just try
a little bit try to try to have some sex
appeal here but then you know in the
kissing challenge in the
you know [ __ ] marry kill whatever yeah
he went for it yeah he did after aj and
he planted it on it yeah and he went in
they they uh snogged for sure yeah they
were smooching
both times right yeah oh yeah they they
smooched that was a hard sure
jake suck yeah yeah that was jake face
sucking what's his last name
toes jake toes
yeah what is what are their last names i
have no idea maybe they're not
they don't give it what let's do a toby
update
my boy rocking a thong yeah
yeah insane move bro watching them crazy
watching them in there was like watching
your sims [ __ ] yeah
like they had such weird energy yeah
like i agree
everyone's like getting ready for bed
and it cuts to them he's just like
dancing in the corner and she's like
yeah
yeah what what was her yeah
he's in the corner
[Laughter]
sucking the chocolate off each other and
they're not saying anything you're just
laughing every single time yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then the next day she was like she
was like to the camera like
well you know when two people are very
sexually attracted to each other
and you give them edible chocolate it's
only gonna go one way
and i was like i didn't really get any
sex appeal between you guys
yeah honestly you know it feels like
they're forcing it a little bit
they they elena actually
described it pretty accurately she's
like they're like uh
they're like a villain couple in a
teenage movie yeah
like they're just like you know pee on
his face babe
yeah yeah i'm gonna pee on his face yeah
yeah yeah
and then they're just that all the time
have we talked about when toby was
torn up about the the fact that america
voted them like
not one of the most compatible couples
so funny so funny
dude does not like losing yeah that was
so weird he was
so bent out of shape about the fact that
that they didn't get top top five or
they're the bottom three right yeah
yeah they call it going to the camera
calling the uk out straight to the
[ __ ] face
i don't get it like we've got massive
chemistry
it's like dude why did why does it
matter dude and then he goes to kaz and
goes
makes me think i went about things the
wrong way with you and i
yeah yeah i kind of do yeah but
yeah why why he cared so much was
bizarre yeah
and then even how pissed off chloe got
about that yeah i understand being like
annoyed
she was like that's so fake
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah that's what we should have seen in
the hideaway actually yeah we didn't
really see any
yeah just literally eating him actually
it kind of was that way in the pie
in the pie contest the pie challenge or
whatever when they did the slow-mo
footage of their kiss oh bro the way she
makes out is tongue
first it's wild
that's how she kisses and i really was i
was thinking about the bit that we did
last time
just like going tongue first and then
his [ __ ] face just
[Laughter]
she she looks like like on the bbc
there's like when david attenborough is
like narrating like a [ __ ]
rain tree frog eating grasshoppers in
the air
just like
here we are with chloe
about to suck a toby
we're in the bottom
just oh it's all the way up to here all
you see is a man
thong yeah